tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovissimo video sono da ieri e oggi
siamo tornati su uno scarafaggio dei
paschi ragazzi da oggi fare un po di
filo degli scartati pacchi perché tra
l'altro partiamo con un palco che penso
che sia uno dei parchi più speciali che
abbiamo mai ricevuto molto strana questa
frase questo fatto ragazzi e un patto
ricevuto da
google adesso mi ha inviato questa
scatola incredibile e andremo ad
abbozzarla perché comunque è una scatola
importante vediamo subito che ci sono
dei ganci ho paura di farmi malissimo
incredibile
tutto a posto
[Musica]
abbiamo delle corse però c'è una lettera
per le leggo questa a in inglese in
inglese ragazzi google's allusivo a
style gassner lugo ti saluta astronauta
che aspira guardare tutto al camino
governo è spezzato ma ci siamo felici di
averti a bonn al bordo della
space is intercalati giovane in questo
inter grafico yogurt più nello score del
vino organs of service copyrigt la vita
l'importanza della sicurezza bomber in
auto space and round dir while we are on
line sia lassù nello spazio sia qua
quando siamo online
proprie carte lancio ti verrà chiesto di
completare tre differenti missioni uno
per ogni oggetto che troverai
all'interno dello stato
vabbè fa firmò ma paura not self paolo
nespoli team service support you with
his prince al vice lo stellare paolo
nespoli vi aiuterà con i suoi preziosi
consigli grazie paolo nespoli
che così ci da iphone apple i never
trust pierce è un membro de femmes a
nord ovest est dancing all right and my
boys andiamo con il pacchetto divisi e
livelli di belluno 23 questo è il
livello 1
spatial by google dei wine quindi sono
tre scatole in una è un unboxing caption
bellissimo ragazzi questo è un
è una coperta in tv
noi no ragazzi no ragazzi no ragazzi
mi sento un sacco comodo qua dentro
paolo refoli come si apre la tip
comunque ho la mia incredibile tuta
spaziale ma c'è qualcosa che cos'è una
tuta spaziale che non ti può spaziare
bellissimo ma andiamo avanti ragazzi
questo livello 1 veniva seduto
vestiamoci come degli astronauti os x
scelta potrebbe tutto questo è pesante
rara per l'ulteriore no perché sono
veramente curioso nella ripresa ci siamo
ha detto che lo giuro non questa roba
non mi tengo il mio ok
ma che cos'è sta roba c'è dell'acqua
dentro questo è
ciao ragazzi questo è il cibo che
mangiano gli astronauti cede il cibo per
astronauti ma voglio provare questa cosa
energy woodpecker riso pad e poi abbiamo
zuppa di carne che ricci che è il rais
tratto la scadenza ragazzi vi prego da
scadenza nel 2029
c'è il cibo per astronauti a con
osservazioni incredibile domani i
ragazzi farò un intera giornata sopra
cercando di sopravvivere con il cibo per
astronauti però adesso proviamo l'acqua
pazzesco cessa di acqua di farlo sapere
ragazzi se poi sopravvivo mangiando
questa roba però nel frattempo andiamo
avanti passiamo ragazzi quindi al
l'ultimo pacco all'interno del pacco fa
ridere sempre questa rosa e
è un mattone cioè allora alla forma di
un mattone e filo pesa come un mattone
non lo farò cadere vero bollate sia
fragile ma pesa un sacco
idea di cosa possa essere cos'è sta roba
ragazzi e un
cos'è codice da vinci cos'è sta roba è
una password o va bene è un corso per
nascondere rom e un lucchetto e cosa lo
scrittore so io sei lettere sei lettere
space na5 shelter ne ha 7 google ragazzi
proprio con google
puoi vedere che ci amano che mi sta
riprendendo ciao ciao ragazzi ermanno mi
hanno dato un esperto di risoluzione
risoluzioni di ordigni ma che strana in
criminologia alla spetta dunque quante
oa tra l'altro la 2 a 2 ott
no non vi avverto non mi volevo fare qua
e là d'ogni un indizio qualcosa per la
faccia di storaro
chi è che la fa come fai come aspettano
le cacciate poi come che cacciavite a
romperla ma cosa romperlo che cazzo ne
so io ragazzi può essere qualsiasi cosa
nostra come passa di mano lo stop poi vj
proprio peso sembra di giocare a un
horror che io questi così negli horror è
tornare italiani non so da c'è un anno
verranno guardatemi un indizio qualcosa
non posso sapere io non è che lo dice
paolo nespoli
ai client e se in english world
consisting of sex lettere e serre stupro
the key of seven soldiers news.it
bombato e software è tutto chiaro
marino sera proteggere se stesso e
soldato durante le battaglie serve a
proteggere me stesso i soldati lo neri
battaglie di una parola in inglese cos'è
e
cosa mi riserva e battaglia in battaglia
ogni bug e trincee maialata
non l'ho saputa mente in battaglia
l'elmo del met bel mad max no a meno che
non debba stare come no qualcosa non è
mettere
se serve the elmes è sicuro ma tu sei
sicuro che sia il mento non credo cosa
sicura il battaglia per proteggersi ma
che cacchio dello
shield
schiller ragazzi che non era messo in
testa no lui ha detto in testa ha fatto
il gesto in testa
lui ha detto è il menti ho detto scusa
non voglio solo dire che se per caso
azzecco convinto io
[Musica]
subito subì tutto qua
boom un addio
[Musica]
ma
c'è un foglio
pesava una tonnellata in un foglio
pesavano un chilo e mezzo
c'è un quad squad scan and play
scanner play ok
si è aperto
tocca per inizia a è un gioco
space center a eccolo inizia il tuo
viaggio verso la sicurezza ama ragazzi è
un gioco per la nostra sicurezza
google altroconsumo euro consumo
rappresenta non giocava una rampa dalla
no aspetta parte roba troppo avanzata
allora è un gioco sulla sicurezza ma c'è
molto di più facciamoci un gameplay
delicato per adesso concluso qua però
che unboxing incredibile proprio vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi questa era la boxe in
grazie ad uno splendido pacco gigantesco
con tre quarti all'interno è questa tuta
mi rende nostra nota ma non sarò mai
l'impostore questo ricordato noi vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi consente di unire
questo vi piace anche vari social
nella sezione senso non ci si chiede
come sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
beh ragazzi
[Musica]